someone sent me a video yesterday that i
found fascinating because it reminded me
of someone that i've interviewed on the
show who has since passed away that i'm
going to tell you about in a moment this
is a video i'm going to play for you of
a q anon person
who believes that trump and jfk jr jfk
jr not jfk jfk junior a lot of people
are confused by which jfk
uh they believe that this person
believes trump and jfk jr are currently
the president and the vice president and
one of the delightful things i i love
hyper-specific conspiracy theories as
many of you know this guy also claims
that mortgages are invalid that more
that as soon as you sign a mortgage the
mortgage is paid off if some of our
older listeners might remember who this
should remind us of so let's look at
this clip first
sure
sure
did you know all mortgages in the united
states are fraud
every one of them
everyone is fraud did you know your
mortgage was paid off
your mortgage was paid off
the moment you signed the mortgage
application and they accepted it whoa
you know who paid it off
you did huh
so you're not a debtor you're a creditor
you just don't know it
you don't know it
they want you to think you're a debtor
and that you're indebted to them
your signature
paid off that loan immediately
and you don't know why do you okay i'm
going to teach you guys why so this
this i don't know why i find this
fascinating so who does this remind me
of this is a great dip into the archives
for some of our younger viewers there's
this guy who passed away in 2019
his name was david wynn miller
and i interviewed him years ago and
during the interview i'm not going to
play it for you now but you can look it
up it's about 10 20 minutes long he said
things that like for example that he is
the king of hawaii as as one example
that he syntaxed the magna carta but
david win miller's big thing was that
you can make yourself a non-taxable
entity to the united states with
something that he called quantum grammar
and the inclusion of extraneous
punctuation marks in your name so like
his name was david win miller but he
would put like a colon before david and
then a dash between david and nguyen and
he believed that by becoming
uh
quantum grammar you were no longer
taxable and people tried doing this
stuff and they were they were sometimes
held in contempt by courts so here's a
little bit of what david wynn miller
used to do this q anon guy it seems just
like the next version of david wynn
miller when we
went to school they taught us that the
sentence must be one thought right so we
have a
we have a one venue or one condition of
thought which is a correct parse a
syntax grammar parsee syntax grammar was
a favorite word of his and if you're
looking at this you also see that he has
hyphens between like every word on his
whiteboard that was another thing he did
however in the world of fraud
which means you're going to have
going to the store from the house now we
have two different time factors of from
and two which is now a lie because now
we have two conditions of time
and it's no longer a single thought
sentence
so this generates when you're into fraud
fiction lies perjury false guessing
presumption assumption
yeah
when uh my dad was a psychiatrist when i
did the interview with david windmiller
years ago i showed it to him and i said
what do you what do you think about this
guy he's not diagnosing anyone in any
formal way everybody relax
my dad said this guy strikes me as
what's called a paraphrenic it's not a
schizophrenic a paraphrenic is someone
who has a highly organized set of of
delusions
without hallucinations he's this guy's
not hallucinating he just it's a very
organized
sort of like gated set of delusions
and
outside of that they seem like normal
people so sometimes when you have like a
paranoid delusional or schizophrenic
you can't have a normal conversation
with them about anything it's when you
speak them they're very clearly totally
out of touch with reality you can't talk
about the grocery store you can't talk
about sports or whatever
david when miller my dad's instinct not
a formal diagnosis was this is this is a
paraphrenia with this grammar stuff it's
highly organized and limited and outside
of that you you can seemingly have a
normal conversation with a guy here's
one more video from from one of these
weird seminars 92 degree mason is
because in 1988 i broke the math
interface in all 5000 languages proving
that language is a linear craziness
algebra right this hasn't been done in 8
500 years of written language
he broke the math language interface
maybe he could fix my toaster when i did
so i was able to unlock the two-thirds
of all the words missing from all
languages
in the world and i can write any
sentence in any language frontwards and
backwards with the same meaning yeah
even the maori languages he's able to
write uh forwards and backwards so
bizarre stuff and the q anon guy it's
like the same thing let me explain
grammatically why
you are really the one who is owed the
money on the mortgage or whatever the
case may be
wacky stuff but the point is
all of this stuff recycles i've told you
guys that a lot of the modern
revolutionary left sometimes they're
called tankies but it's not a it's sort
of a pejorative the modern revolutionary
left
are really similar
to
the 60s era sort of socialist communists
that were really common in in south
america they were in argentina where i
was born and in other countries it's a
rehashing of the same ideas and the same
ideology and the same sort of tone and
tenor
and even the q anon stuff isn't really
new when they get into these
technicalities about grammar and syntax
david wynn miller did this stuff for 30
years may he rest in peace